Life is Like a Box of Chocolates.
Life throws curveballs at you all the time...
...and it is impossible to know what the future holds for you.
As Mrs. Gump said to her son Forrest in the movie Forrest Gump,...
..."Life is like a box of chocolates,..."
"...you never know what you're gonna get."
I never intended on being a high - level executive of one of the biggest companies in the world.
I actually wanted to be a fireman.
However, one summer vacation during my sophomore year of college,...
...my friend was upset that he could not go on a trip...
...because the temp agency he worked for would not give him time off.
So, I offered to cover for him.
Little did I know that when I said "I wouldn't mind covering for you,"...
...that I would begin the process of changing my life.
Working for a temp agency was interesting...
...and exposed me to all kinds of different office environments and situations.
I loved doing things for people,...
...and I was always going the extra mile, saying, "Would you like me to take the meeting for you?"...
..."Just go home. I'll take care of this,"...
...and "How about I do the report for you?"...
..."I'm interested in the subject anyway."
And so with experience, I have become a successful businessman.
Success is simple.
Go the extra mile and do things others don't want to do.
Focus on your current task and job, and the future will come of its own accord.
After all, life is like a box of chocolates,...
...you never know what you're gonna get.